[Musique]
la nuit tombe sur château pour laisser
place aux lumières
la ville organise son deuxième festival
des lumières impressionniste jusqu'au 10
septembre
vous allez avoir une mise en lumière de
tous les bâtiments donc voilà des
mappings sur sur les maisons le 20
heures le restaurant fournel il va y
avoir des des promenades sur la scène
avec des bateaux illuminés de la musique
des spectacles de danse voilà toutes ces
choses qui font que ça fait vivre ce
merveilleux site en tout cas les
visiteurs peuvent également visiter le
musée fournaise en accès libre durant la
soirée en immersion le spectateur
découvre la vie du célèbre peintre
impressionniste renoir mais cette année
celui qui est célébrée c'est edgar degas
il est assez jeune c'est à peu près au
même moment où renoir et monnet viennent
aussi peindre sur les bords de seine
tous ces artistes flamands sont attirés
par des lieux qui correspondent à leur
génération on vient chez les fournaises
on vient dans les restaurants du coin
pour faire la fête et puis ils sont à la
recherche tous de nouveaux sujets pour
qu'il se puisse se distinguer des
générations précédentes d'artistes qui
eux travaillent et du côté de
fontainebleau château c'est à la mode
avec toute la boucle de la seine qui est
dans le coin et on vient faire la fête
l'objectif de ce festival rendre
l'histoire de l'art accessible à tous
pour animer la soirée un marché nocturne
artisanal s'installera en bord de seine
le 9 et le 10 septembre les curieux
pourront également assister à des
spectacles de danse et de cirque
[Musique]